this
is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice number one
best-selling author ramsey personality
christie wright is my co-host today
open phones as we take your calls about
your life and your money the phone
number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five a couple weeks ago we
launched the pre-sale on her new book
take back your time
the guilt-free guide to balanced living
you gotta check it out and guess what we
got in the books today so we're ready to
ship
when september 14th occurs which is the
actual street date on the book but
they're in the warehouse we're actually
touching and looking at real books not
mock-ups
not uh advanced reader copies this is
the this is the real thing it's the real
thing it came in today
tyler surprised me with it and i walked
around the corner i was like oh my gosh
now it's real it's in my hands i can't
wait to
take one home and show my husband there
you go well this is your second one so
it's like
you know i mean doing a book is a lot of
work it takes a year
in some ways it's more trouble than
having a kid well and it's funny because
the process is so
lonely you know it's you and a computer
and microsoft word documents and then
the team through editing and design and
layout makes it something so beautiful
like this gosh it just brings it to life
yeah good stuff take back your time the
guilt-free guide
to life balance you can get it on
pre-sale we launched ken coleman's book
on monday on pre-sale as well
uh from paycheck to purpose both of
those are 20. they're both at
ramseysolutions.com
and they both include an extra hundred
dollars worth of
goodies meaning uh all kinds of extra
add-ons like the e-book and the audio
book and
other things as well now you did a uh a
live stream last week
yeah on this subject how to go it was
great it was awesome we talked about the
source of why you feel out of balance
because one of the things i found dave
is that
we don't know what balance is we just
know we don't have it and so i wanted to
peel away the layers and say okay let's
talk about the four main causes
of why you feel out of balance in the
first place which i unpack in the book
and we talked about that and talked
about what to do about it so it was a
great a great live session i think the
replay is available by the way on
youtube or facebook if anybody wants to
watch that from last wednesday
oh okay cool perfect good stuff all
right check out this material it is
life-changing and if you want to talk
about life balance or life or money
this is what we're here for the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five we answer questions
about a little bit of everything around
here
tammy's gonna start off this hour in
sarasota florida hi tammy how are you
good afternoon thank you thank you for
taking my call
my question is regarding umbrella
insurance policies
are they worth it do they just entice
people to sue
more frequently or go after more beyond
that as well
no i i don't think there's any
indication of that i i think that
people are enticed in a lawsuit happy
world
to sue for anything anyway and so um
i i think they're worth it i mean you
can get a million dollar umbrella policy
that attaches to the top of uh the
liability on your car and your
homeowners
which is usually up to a half a million
so that gives you like a million and a
half total
uh in most areas you can get that for
200 300
something like that from an independent
insurance broker or from your insurance
broker to match up with your
your current uh your current coverage on
your pnc
and yeah it's worth it once you've got a
a
net worth or something that gives
someone the indication
that they might uh be able to get
something out of you
and so in a lawsuit happy world for 300
bucks i i
always recommend that when you got a
half million dollar net worth and above
or if you're doing something uh that
makes people
think that you do you talk about that
with um women in
business or anybody in business but
specifically you and i've had
conversations around this around
business boutique
women that are in a business that either
they have
a lot of wealth or even the appearance
of wealth that would make someone want
to sue them
and then it's a good idea whenever
anyone thinks about that from an
incorporating standpoint you know you
talk about that you know for instance
uh if you're doing something that you
know we around here we call it spotlight
work where you're in the media
um or you're in a spotlight of some kind
or
that gives people the idea that that
that you know you could be uh you'd be
right for the picking if they if you
happen to bump into them with your car
yeah and so uh i carry a 10 million
um on me uh because if i bump into
somebody they're gonna go oh yeah
everything's okay
uh what's your name dave ramsey oh god
my back you know so
um you know that that's uh that that's
that's kind of the way i'm looking you
know i'm a little bit cynical
uh and i have a good reason to be
so uh yeah i think they're worth it to
answer your question and we recommend
them once you've gotten up
now you don't need one if you've got a
negative net worth or a hundred thousand
dollar net worth or something
uh unless you're doing something that
gives the appearance
uh some you know all i'm trying to do is
hand off the lawsuit to an insurance
company
because it doesn't change anything but
they're gonna they're gonna fight it or
settle it or whatever they're gonna do
um versus me
that's all amounts to i can self-insure
through a million dollars or 10 million
hit uh but for the few dollars that it
costs to buy it it's it's it's a really
good
buy in the insurance world to not have
to deal with it yeah i just uh
you know and they they can go over and
the sad thing is is they
they're they'll settle a lot quicker
than i would yeah
because i i can't stand the fraud so i
get
i get all principled about it and then
i'll run this into the ground
it turns into a long fight it's an
expensive fight and they'll the
goobs at the insurance companies will
just write a check you know so
ravens in atlanta georgia hi raven how
are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um i just wanted to know whether or not
to pay off my mortgage
or i'm about to inherit some land and i
wanted
we want to save to go to house which one
would be the better option
we owe about 50k on our house now and we
earn about 14k
by airbnb in it okay
well it's kind of the same thing because
you're going to sell your house to pay
off
to build the house eventually and so
paying off your house is like saving it
because you're not going to keep it not
not and go get a mortgage on your build
it
on your new house you build not a fight
not if you do what i tell you to do
anyway
so no i would not i would not keep a
paid for house as a rental and then go
take out a mortgage to build a house no
i would not do that
so i'm going to tell you to sell your
house at that point when you're ready to
build
so the money's going to come out of it
and so either way the money is going to
be available for the build
okay that makes sense so just yes i
mainly just throw it at the mortgage
that way
it's for sure safe yeah i mean and
here's the thing
if you decided to go build a home um
you could take out a construction loan
which is what most people do
if they're going to borrow money that is
to build a home on the land
and uh the the bank doing that's going
to require you
get a pre-approval for your permanent
mortgage that's called a take-out letter
uh
to to show that you can convert the
construction loan to a permanent
mortgage at the time the
loan is finished and part of that will
be you know we're going to sell our
house
like the month before the house is
completed
so we can we move in and we're going to
free up all of that money and it'll be
the down payment on the
and you'll have a you know a mortgage or
no mortgage or whatever you have at that
point out of that construction loan so
the um construction loan will be larger
than the permanent because you'll
sell your house and use the money out of
it i guess that makes sense that makes
sense that makes sense yeah okay
yeah so that's what you do and um
i love pay i love paying down the house
versus throwing it in savings because
it's harder to buy a bass boat with that
money
it's accounted for you can't get to it
as easy
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five her new book is
on pre-sale called
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life
balance if you've ever made a dumb
decision with zeros on the end because
you didn't do your research
well that'd be all of us right we've all
done this most people make choices
sadly based on feelings or opinions and
sometimes they do this on something big
like a house
oh when it comes to the real estate
market feelings are
not your friends the facts are your
friends
so check your facts find out what you
can actually afford research what's
trending in home prices
talk to a reputable real estate agent in
your area never buy a house without the
facts
go to ramseysolutions.com agent you can
get one of our endorsed local providers
ramsey trusted and they will take care
of you
they're people that we've vetted to be
the top real estate agents in your area
that's ramsey solutions dot com slash
agent our question today comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free even if you screwed it up
i like this guarantee uh you get free
samples
free shipping new promos every month
always use the promo code ramsey
to get the best possible deal today's
question comes from caleb in ohio i'm a
skilled
trades apprentice and currently make 30
an hour i'm married to a beautiful wife
and we have a 10 month old baby
ever since the coveted lockdown started
my wife has been left
unemployed she went to college and has a
degree in psychology i can work overtime
at my job and could potentially bring in
home
an extra thousand to 1500 a month we are
a hundred and eighty thousand dollars in
debt
including our mortgage she loves staying
home with the baby but i think it would
be highly beneficial for her to have a
good
paying job should she get a job
oh like
this sounds like a fight yeah
yeah well first okay i want to challenge
one thing at the beginning of this uh
since coveted lockdown she's been left
unemployed
there are job opportunities people are
hurting
for employees everywhere all the time
and
she has the potential to do something on
her own so it's not that there's not an
opportunity out there i want to
challenge that
first of all that's true the issue is
she hadn't been looking for an
opportunity because she would stay home
with the kids
she's like oh there's nothing out there
babe sorry i checked i checked
i worked on it for like a minute and a
half today there's nothing there's
nothing out there shucks i'm gonna have
to stay home with this adorable baby
yeah try it again yeah you know what's
interesting is and and this is like so
many questions we get dave
is it's a values question more than a
money question yes there's a financial
piece of it if she got a job you all
would get out of debt faster that's a
that's a
financial mathematical equation but but
then you look at the cost of child care
too it would have to be something that
makes more
than what you're paying in child care to
make sense if you are
paying for child care which is a major
variable in there
but i think it's interesting too because
the idea of women staying home
is something that is extremely um what's
the word
emotionally triggering polarizing people
have a lot of opinions on
um i don't know yeah i think they have
two opinions in that house he wants her
to go to work she doesn't want to yeah
um so that's problem number one yeah
uh you guys need to get on the same page
on that because i got a feeling caleb
you completely stacked this this whole
i mean here's an example caleb how badly
you screwed up your intent here
um we're 180 000 in debt including our
mortgage
so what 179 000 of it's the mortgage we
don't know
you completely stacked that we're so
deeply in debt is what you're trying to
say and that's a bunch of crap i'm
calling you on
we're sinking dave send her to work sit
tell her she's she she needs to go to
the salt mines
now but the uh all right so here's the
thing
uh i think the first thing you two need
to agree on
is if we can afford it and our
family is going to be okay are we on the
same page that she stays home
yeah and you're not there yeah and
that's so cool
i'm reading in between the lines oh
caleb wants to go to work even if they
were millionaires
100 and what's so important about that
piece of it
is that if you're not on the same page
and you continue to function this way
you're going to resent her
yeah she's getting tired of being
treated like she's lazy
caleb you're gonna mistakenly think that
she does nothing all day
and let me tell you right now a baby is
not a vacation and she
she does work it's just at home so
that's the first piece of
but if she does go to work to make him
happy she's going to resent that
so getting on the same page to avoid the
resentment building up between you guys
is going to be so important
so at what number at what point in your
finances
are you both going to be in agreement
because right now there's not any number
i can read it in here i
don't believe there's a number and you
caleb you need to determine
at what point you are comfortable with
her staying home
and if that's never you need to look in
the mirror
okay so uh that's an issue because
your wife has said i want to stay home
with a kid
and uh this is your kid your wife so
that's an issue
to just declare everyone who stays home
with a kid lazy regardless of the
numbers
is pretty much asinine caleb so um
you know that's not that's not an option
you can't put that on the table here uh
and so now if she wants to work
that's a whole different story
absolutely and and if she wants to work
no matter what
the income is um that's a different
story too
and so uh i mean in your case you you
got three kids
uh you enjoy being a ramsey personality
in the work time
it's a lot of hours sometimes and matt
makes plenty of money yeah you would you
easily could stay home yeah yeah but you
do you get fulfillment here
and have chosen that yeah uh and so
that's a that's a completely different
equation too
but and rachel too yeah my daughter one
of your best friends the same thing
so um uh but but so anyway
now at what point can she
stay home if you guys can pay your bills
and you can eat and you can move ahead
and i'm thinking you can with what you
make in ohio
then if she wants to stay home
mathematically i think she probably can
now or you could set some interim goals
that says okay
once we hit this break then we're going
to make that call once we finish off the
non-mortgage debt yeah then we'll make
that call
or something like that what's
interesting too that i'd be and i'm sure
if they if they went to counseling about
this
i'm sure counselor would actually dig
into it but i wonder what the hang up is
for caleb it might be financial it may
not there may be something where it's
like there's a level of
expectation that he sees in work ethic
or something you need to dig into and
unpack and deconstruct and get on the
same page
that it's not just a number because your
point there may not be a number it may
be something else in him
that is a hang up and so y'all getting
on the same page there is going to be
so so important that's how it sounds in
the in the email to me well and
one more thing on that that's one of the
things i love helping women do with
business beauty because a lot of women
in our business boutique audience in my
coaching group that come to the event
they have that desire to stay home but
have a desire to do something else and
they don't want to work a traditional
nine to five in an office job so they
start a business from home during nap
hours so
there's also other options between her
just working
50 hours a week outside the home so just
she might make more than
at that than something else too yes by
the way absolutely yeah
a lot of the ladies in business boutique
do yes yes lots of options rich is with
us he's in newark new jersey hi rich how
are you
hello hi what's up
can you hear me yes sir how are you good
i i got a quick question dave i'm 76
years old
i got 1.2 million dollars sitting in six
different savings account my house is
paid
votes paid calls paid i owe no debt at
all
good for you should i move it huh good
for you well done rich
except that i don't know what to do
what a great problem to have
oh yeah but it is good
but uh i don't know
well um what do you think
i personally i mean i'm not that far
behind you i'm 60. i personally would
have that money invested
and here's why okay if you were in good
growth stock mutual funds and you made
10
that'd be 120 000 a year uh
right now you're making 12 000 a year
you're making nothing you're making
nothing yeah
yeah and so if i'm if i'm half wrong if
the stock market does half of what it
normally does
you're still going to make 5x of what
you're making right now
now you don't have to move it all over
there and the main barrier to moving it
over there is usually fear
and fear is dissipated by one of two
things one is you come to realize that
the fear is
accurate which means you would not do it
or you come to understand the things
the stock market better by sitting and
meeting with someone to help you walk
through that click smart vester ramsey
solutions.com and you can sit down with
somebody to help you with that
and learn take your time but learn and
let's start moving some of that money
gradually into the market
christie wright ramsey personality
number one best-selling author
is my co-host today in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt-free stage
matt and amber are with us hey guys how
are you
good how are you better than i deserve
welcome where do you all live
houston texas well welcome to nashville
how much debt have you guys paid off
ninety two thousand six hundred and ten
dollars
awesome how long did that take eight
years 11 months and two weeks
eight years 11 months wow
and your range of income during that
time uh it rains uh
60 to 150. wow okay and what do you guys
do for a living i'm in
cyber security and i occasionally worked
at a church but mostly a stay-at-home
mom
good for you cool very cool just what we
were just talking about yeah
yeah and uh what kind of debt was this
93 000
it included our mortgage hey
you paid off your household people
i'm mary what's this house worth uh
one about 170 now wow how old are you
guys
i just turned 40 and i'm 37. how you
paid off your house
yes that's weird y'all are weird
that is i love it way to go
very cool well tell us the story how did
this happen i mean how did you find us
what are you doing yeah well it started
in 2008
when we got married and a friend gave us
a copy of the total money makeover
for a wedding gift so we read that and
then we saw that our church offered fpu
so we took the class and just after our
first
anniversary we finished paying off our
consumer debt
wow so we just kept working the baby
steps
we saved our emergency fund saved for a
down payment for a house
and then we took out a 15-year mortgage
right before our first child was born
and just kept plugging away until about
three and a half years ago when matt was
diagnosed with cancer
oh wow so we kind of had to slow things
down a bit and
take care of that sure but um that
we were thankful to be on the plan at
that point to not have to worry about
the financial side of things when that
was going on
but it also renewed in me a sense that
you know i wanted to finish our goal
together of paying off the house
so we had been setting aside money to
upgrade
matt's car but when our car savings
got close to the amount left on our
mortgage i thought i can't spend this
money on a car
sorry
the upgrade is a happy wife yeah yeah
exactly
that's so true okay so i'm curious when
y'all bought this house y'all were on
the plan
and you bought this house were y'all
intending to get intense about playing
out paying off this mortgage early
or was that something that kind of set
in later i had always wanted to pay off
the house early probably
earlier than he wanted to but i was
more intense um than he was it sounds
like you worked the baby steps exactly
as
outlined yeah we did and and i mean you
worked right into the 15 year
after you were debt-free and had your
emergency fund in place and
then you said okay we're gonna take a 15
but we're going to pay it early yeah and
uh
then everything's cooking along and then
the little hiccups so how are you doing
matt you're
the other side of the cancer uh i'm
feeling good i finished my last
treatment about three months ago
so hopefully that never comes back hey
man uh we're praying and hoping
that's right yeah i'm feeling pretty
good good to be here okay yeah
i mean you're just surviving the cure is
part of it in it yeah
the other part was the medical bills
yeah and
we found out what uh what our out of max
pocket would be
out-of-pocket maximum would be and we
saved that each year
and then after that we would decide okay
we're going to put more towards the
mortgage or save for this
save for that and it was very peaceful
yeah well it's so interesting that you
use the word peaceful when you're
talking about going through
cancer and having to deal with that
because i know so many people that's the
opposite they would ever
think but when you have your finances in
order like you guys did
then it takes that piece of it off of it
and where you're just focused on healing
and getting the treatment you need and
so well done you guys that's amazing i'm
so glad you guys had that foundation
before this came definitely way to go
way to go
how does it feel to be completely free
now i mean the cancer treatments are
over and the house has paid off
touched it's like spring is here yeah
after the winter
yeah it feels great it still feels a
little surreal um
but yeah it feels wonderful so when's
matt get his upgrade
yeah that's a great question on the list
for us to do it's fine no payments
that's going to happen quick
no payments you can you can save for
those goals so much faster
yeah yeah that's amazing you guys well
congratulations you guys very well
thank you all right so you've read the
total money makeover you went through
financial peace university at your
church
you pay off your house and everything
40 years old and younger
what's the secret to getting out of debt
i think the the first step was the the
budget and getting on the same page
we met every month and we looked at the
budget
and we're like okay where is this money
going to go and that
diligence that tenacity of
we're going to meet even if we don't
want to and sometimes we're late
in the middle of the month or so the
beginning of the month but just being on
the same page that was so powerful i
think
and uh agreeing and and making
compromises when we disagreed i think
that was very important
what kept you motivated for the long
haul because this was a long journey for
you guys from the time you paid off your
last consumer debt to now the house is a
big that's a big thing to pay off
what kept you motivated through the
journey just being able to do this
together and have that
weight off our shoulders especially
after the diagnosis just thinking
okay i don't want to have to deal with
anything else i don't have to
so let's just go ahead and get that done
and focus on the other things and
have fun and enjoy life together yeah
good for you
yeah way to go guys you guys are heroes
you completely changed your life changed
your family tree changed everything and
pushed through man well done well done
very well done
so proud of you well we've got a copy of
the legacy journey for you
that is the next chapter in your story
for sure to become
baby steps millionaires you're right
around the corner from that and uh
and and then move on to change your
whole family tree also an extra copy of
the total money makeover to give away
that's what started your journey you can
help somebody start theirs with it
that'll be perfect
and you brought the kiddos with you what
are their names and ages we have hope
ryan and luke
and they are nine seven and five all
right and have they been practicing a
debt free screening
oh yes we have i know what it is right
they're ready to go absolutely
all geared up you guys look like you're
ready to yell
yeah we drove all the way from houston
we're ready yeah that's great
all right here we go i love it matt
amber hope ryan and luke from houston
texas
ninety-three thousand 000 paid off
that's the house and everything they're
weird eight years 11 months did it
making 60 to 150 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
all right three two
i love seeing the kids oh i love it
that's amazing
fabulously done very well done
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five those guys are
amazing what great heroes
teresa is in dayton ohio hi teresa how
are you
i'm well how are you dave better than we
deserve what's up
well i was calling i'm trying to decide
so um
my mom's been like very sick for the
past year and
there's a lot of care and stuff that
i kind of manage with her and i'm i've
been looking
i've been on the journey since like
right before covent um
and and that's free other than the house
and stuff that i've been looking at
i mean you've really motivated me and
and just trying to find a path with god
and you know trying to help other people
out too
and i just i want to do the financial
coaching
but i just don't know if this is the
time
just because of the over willingness
with my mom and stuff yeah yeah
it might not be it might be that you
spend your time best with mom right now
it sounds to me like
i'm just listening to your voice um
there's no shame in that no there's not
and um
here's a good way to think through it
you know all the details when you are
um 25 years older than you are today
and you look back on this season which
thing are you going to be glad you did
theresa i just talked about this on
instagram today i just want to encourage
you
this is your season of taking care of
your mom this is where you are
this is not who you are just because
you're not pursuing that right now
doesn't mean you're never going to
your season is where you are not who you
are you do what's right right now
and you'll know what to do next and when
you look back
you smile and go i did the right thing
at the right time that's right
whatever that is this is the ramsey chef
chrissy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author
is my co-host today we launched her new
book and it is
uh in pre-sale is selling like crazy
called take back
let me try it again take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance
all about uh this elusive thing that
everybody talks about being balanced
um which really is a misnomer but
christie addresses all that beautifully
and
uh it's kind of sets you free to where
you can live your life well
and uh and with a level of
intentionality and you're gonna love
this material it's incredible aaron is
with us in orlando
hi aaron how are you i'm doing great
dave how are you doing today
better than we deserve what's up
i wanted to call dave because my wife
and i would like to ask a question about
upgrading our housing situation
we're currently on baby step six right
now and we're
we've maxed out our uh 401k roth uh
contributions as well as an additional
six thousand per roth ira
and during a time of pandemic when we've
seen so many people struggling
we've been so fortunate where our
careers have really really blossomed
and a big dream of my wife has always
been to move to a certain area in
orlando as well as myself
and upgrade our housing and right now we
have the ability to save on average
about an additional fifty to seventy
five thousand dollars a year
that would like to put towards making
this purchase
we wanna be patient about this purchase
because there's not a lot of houses that
come up for sale in this area
regularly when they do they go very very
quickly and we're just not in that
position quite yet
so my question for you is would you take
this additional 50 to 75 000
that we're making additionally on an
annual basis
and just pay down our current mortgage
or would you take that and put that
maybe in a gross
mutual stock uh or mutual funds uh
arena to let it grow and then use that
towards
um paying uh towards the down payment of
the house when we find the right deal at
the right time
oh you're going to sell your house
aren't you absolutely
sure you're going to get your money out
of it anyway
correct we we currently owe about 230
000 on our home right now
and it's worth over four hundred so we
have a video let's just say that
let's just say your careers continued to
blossom and you paid it off
yes sir and then you found the house in
the dream neighborhood
you just put that one on the market and
sell it and use that for the down
payment right
correct my wife um she she's the one
that's getting more analytical about it
she's wondering if we're better off
using it and seeing maybe that eight
percent growth on it as opposed to just
we're paying right now 2.625 on our
mortgage rate
and she thought maybe be better off you
know investing it there and seeing
growth there rather than paying down the
mortgage itself
yeah that's when you didn't do math um
because here's the problem okay the way
you get into that new neighborhood
has got 95 percent to do
with you saving 50 to 100 000 a year
it has one percent to do with what the
rate of return on your savings is
the math that gets you into that
neighborhood is not is not rate of
return
it's your savings rate based on your
income
so you know if you want to use that
argument that she's using we would never
pay off the mortgage
correct yes my contention is i'd like to
pay off the mortgage because i would
like to
be able to do my debt free screen no
matter what well yeah
and in either way either way you get to
your goal
uh but the the idea that that somehow
making a little bit more on your money
is going to get you to the goal faster
no you're adding risk to the equation
and i wouldn't do that
i would continue to work your plan and
the other thing i think i heard is that
you're putting more than 15
of your income into retirement correct
sir
yeah because i would hold up at baby
step 4 at 15 going into retirement
and i would throw everything else at the
mortgage that's the baby steps
the the additional amount is more
towards uh looking towards the kids for
their education for college
you know i'm said 15 towards retirement
oh yeah you said you maxed out
everything are your income so high that
maxing out everything
uh is 15 of your income
um i believe the maximum a lot we're
allowed to
deposit right now is it 18 000 750 or
something like that
this year well this year's 1905 yeah
yeah
so we we've matched that out completely
and then we started
is that more than 15 of your income
yes it is sir okay that's not what i
don't know i'm sorry
all right i'm sorry uh i'm sorry it is
well it is more i'm sorry i i
i yeah and so you're putting in 22 to 25
of your income instead of 15 of your
income i would back
that down throw everything at your house
let's get your house paid for
pile up cash once the house is paid for
beyond that
um but um yeah so so
yeah you guys uh i mean that's what we
teach
again you can do your plan if you're
under your plan but 15
is the most of your household income
take your household income times 0.15 is
the most i'd be putting into those
401ks and roth iras anything beyond that
kids college anything beyond that we're
paying down the house going to get it
paid for and then you'll be ready
christy to move into that other house
well the other thing that uh that i love
that you pointed out dave is it's not
just about the money as it is we're
talking about like where you put the
money
the risk and so aaron you want to get in
this special neighborhood that's hard to
get into
you're going to be in a really good
position if you have hardly any mortgage
or a paid off house and then some saved
up cash
when you make an offer on a home in any
kind of market
versus worrying about what the mutual
funds are doing or whatever you're just
gonna have so much more control
to make a good offer and have a good
position for that house you want and
that's what we're trying to help you do
we're trying to help you get in a good
position
financially but also from a control
standpoint in options
yeah so you guys are um again you can
work your plan your wife's plan if you
want to
that's allowed well you know there's
nothing against the law
but we are firmly convinced after 30
years of doing this that if you will
follow those baby steps
exactly you're going to find yourself
in wealth faster than any other
methodology
and we've actually got millions and
millions of people that have done it
that are the data points that indicate
that
it's not it's not a you know college
professor with a theory
um been doing this a long time with tens
of millions of people
we were just we're just saying as we
walked out in the break to congratulate
those people debt-free on their house
we're seeing a lot more people paying
off their homes and it's a result of
those
tens you know it's the number of years
yeah the 30 years of doing this
you know when i hadn't been on the air
eight years i couldn't have somebody
come in here and go eight years ago i
started listening to you and
but now that i've been on the air 30
years there's a whole bunch of them that
are
out there that um that you know they're
further along and we're also seeing the
you know the other piece of it which is
the financial piece of babies my parents
listened to you when i was a kid oh
shut up you know but um
yeah just make they feel old statement
but
um but you don't have to make me feel
old i'm well aware of my age but the uh
uh
but uh you know uh the thing is this
stuff works it's
always worked it still works you know
ramsay's
people are out of touch no we're not
we're in touch with the truth
uh we know exactly how wealth is built
in today's world the fastest possible
way
and there's a lot of stuff we don't
think about around here but that's not
one of them we
we're we are the expert on that in in
the whole freaking nation
so and it's you know it's not um
my age does not disqualify that as a
matter of fact it qualifies it
so well you don't understand modern yes
i do you goob
i understand modern everything i can
even work my own phone
go figure you know so but this idea that
that somehow
that the principles of wealth building
have somehow
shifted dramatically in the past 10
years and ramsay's a boomer and doesn't
get it
it's just asinine yeah just ridiculous
so the principles are all have always
been the same they will always be the
same
and uh now the vehicles you use might
shift some of those things might change
but
you know you don't you can't use that to
be uh to make an excuse to get in to get
rich quick garbage well you make you
always make a good point too don't take
financial advice from broke people and
half the time the people that are
telling you
you should be doing this you have to
build a credit score you have to take
out debt you have to have a mortgage you
should put your money in this
whatever they're people that are deeply
in debt there are people that are not
winning financially these are not the
kind of people you want to listen to
if the financial blogger you're reading
lives in his mother's basement there's a
problem here
you know i mean we need a track record
we need proof there's just a there's a
little bit of
something going on here i got socks
older than him
so um but that that's the trick you just
got to think this through
and um you know uh there there isn't
a thing called experience and proof
texting
in that experience chrissy wright ramsey
personality my co-host today
james childs is our producer kelly
daniels our associate producer and phone
screener i'm dave ramsey your host we'll
be back with you before you know it
here on the ramsay show
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey your
host
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money my co-host today christy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author
launching her second best-selling book
in pre-sale that's a prediction
a couple of weeks ago it's called take
back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance
so if you want to talk about life life
balance money
that's what we're here for it's a free
call some say the advice is worth
exactly what you pay for it
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five
two forest is with us in
fayetteville north carolina hey forest
how are you
hi dave and christy it's an honor to
talk to you guys youtube
what's up so i'm 25
and i just started my first job after
college
i have no student loans no credit card
debt i have three grand to the bank and
three grand in
single stock and i'm looking to propose
to my significant other and i'm looking
into
moving and living with her and so my
question was
what would you recommend when planning
to purchase an
engagement ring starting to save for a
wedding and that would be
two years from now and what would be
your recommendation for investment
because i really haven't done any at the
moment
okay cool what do you make
about 60 000 a year what's your
potential fiance make
she'll be a high school teacher so
anywhere between 30 and 40 to start out
with
okay so like 100 household income when
you're married right
yes okay well here's a couple of rules
of thumb
uh engagements and weddings are really
important
no kidding dave so uh
and they can both get emotional and
people get stupid
about what they spend on both things so
here's a couple of guidelines for you to
think about
uh since you're gonna be saving up for
the wedding
the cheaper the wedding the sooner the
date
that makes sense that makes sense to me
because i heard you say two years
because it was going to take that long
to save the money
when it doesn't take that long to run
down to the justice of the peace by
saturday
this is true i wasn't gonna suggest that
i'm just saying that there's a ratio
here
that the cheaper the wedding the faster
it occurs okay
that makes sense so uh if if you were my
kid i would say don't wait two years
so that you don't move in together
before marriage
don't shack up ahead of time and let's
let's plan a uh
an inexpensive wedding but a nice
wedding and let's get married in
five or six months if you were my kid
that's what i would tell you
okay now then on the on to the
engagement ring
a good rule of thumb the jewelry stores
tell you three months of your income
and that's because they sell jewelry
so a good rule of thumb is one month of
income
maximum so um sweetie's getting a uh
4 000 3 000 ring max
because that's your take-home pay
which by the way gets you real dadgum
married
sharon's was 1164.
and 39 years later it's still working
good
okay
you with me i think we lost him i think
you scared him
are you gone did i blow did i blow you
out of the saddle he's like you killed
all my dreams out of here
well you were okay what were you
thinking of spending on the ring
i was thinking somewhere between three
and five oh okay
we're on the same we're in the same
ballpark you weren't going to go crazy
because there is no correlation between
the size of the diamond and the success
of the marriage
as a matter of fact there might be an
inverse correlation
at some point okay meaning that you
if a large rock is required the size of
a headlight this is probably not a
not the girl of your dreams but um it's
the girl of your nightmares but anyway
the um
so that if that's a requirement so i
think you got you're on track there
and so dude i mean listen like we're
talking 10 grand here gets this whole
puppy done and then you move on with
other stuff but in the meantime these
things are top of the line
what do you think christy yeah i think
the only other thing i would question is
for us figure out what your
um what your monthly expenses are and
just make sure that you
keep some savings for your emergency
fund when you're making i don't want you
to drain your 3 000
in a savings account for the ring and
not have any savings
this is on top of your savings yeah you
need to cash out this stock and stuff
so you got six grand to work with you
need about 10 and you
so you could be married by christmas
with a ten thousand dollar wedding and a
three thousand dollar ring
if budget's what's holding if budgets
what's holding up the calendar i don't
know if it is but that's what i
thought i heard did i hear that you said
two years very definitively where'd that
two years come from and don't let him
put words in your route
if it's not money tell us you just be
honest for us what are we working with
here why two years
so me personally i want
to be able to
actually live with her a little bit
before
i actually marry her and spend the rest
of my life with her now this is not
this is a woman it's not shoes
you don't have to try them on and see if
they fit
you do what you want to do but um
you know i uh you know
the actual statistical correlation
between people that shack up before
getting married versus those that don't
the there is very detailed research on
that
and uh this it increases the success
ratio in your marriage your marriage
staying together to not do that
um and so it there's data
on this okay tons tons of pieces of
research on this
and yet there are more people live
together in america today without
marriage than marriage
well and when you when you move in
together it can often be really hard
matt and i moved in together when we got
married and it was hard so if you're
using that as your lipness test to
determine if you want to marry her
i don't know that's an a that's a good
idea you may change your mind
and she could be the one but it was a
hard first six months because why do you
fold the towels that way i mean
you have some interesting things wrong
with you the toothpaste
no you don't load the dishwasher that
way that first year
squeeze a roll i'm just saying it's just
bad yeah but the uh
i mean we've been married 39 years
sharon says we had 25 good years of
marriage
so i'm just saying that that goes that's
part of the equation
you do what you want to do brother we're
here to help you and love you and tell
you the truth and tell you what we
believe
and uh these are these are this advice
comes from
a point of caring and it comes from
uh data data and research and
it comes uh so the average wedding in
america days 28 000 for those of you
listening the average household income
is right about 60. so people are
spending about 50
percent of their household income on
average on their wedding
that's the average now that's a lot
that's a lot uh that's not to say a 28
000 wedding is evil
but if you spend over half your annual
income you'd be over
average and that's a double lot so
um we've got lots of our team members 20
somethings all through this building get
married for 10 grand and had some really
nice little weddings
we've had some people spend a lot more
than that including some ramsey girls
but we had the money
so there's that feels like a really big
deal before it's here and then
afterwards
it doesn't feel like it's big of a deal
when you're married you got you've got
new priorities
we're cleaning out the closets right now
the organizer ladies there and we're
finding all this stuff from 30 years ago
and we're going 20 years ago 10 years
ago the kids weddings our weddings wow
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text and
six gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70
a month by switching to pure top just go
to puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five
does it feel like no matter what you do
or how hard you work you can't get ahead
you feel like a
rat trapped in a wheel run run run run
run run run run run get nowhere
i remember that feeling it's exhausting
stressful sometimes even terrifying
but you know what you don't have to live
like that if you get sick and tired of
being sick and tired then you can decide
you can say i've had it
i'm not gonna live like this anymore
then you're ready to commit to a new
plan financial peace university is the
step-by-step plan that's helped
millions and millions and millions of
people not only pay off debt
not only learn to work together if
they're married not only take control
but also become wealthy
and you combine that with a premium
version of the every dollar budgeting
tool the world's best budgeting app
and you will make progress right away
and it's only available
through a membership of ramsey plus
decide today to break the cycle of
living paycheck to paycheck this month
only we're taking
30 off the price of the 12-month
membership
and you can start a free trial of ramsey
plus today by texting trial to 33
789 this is unbelievably inexpensive now
text trial two three three
seven eight nine jim is in finley ohio
hi jim welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hey what's up
well i have a little conundrum so um
back in november i was laid off from my
job of
many years due to covid and i was able
to find another job
which i started in mid-january and
unfortunately was in
a different state so i i had kids in
high school i wasn't going to move them
during the school year
i moved down family
you're cutting out all last thing you
heard was you moved down and you're then
your phone cut out
try again i'm sorry about that so yeah i
moved down
and the rest of the family was going to
join me after the school year started
um soon after
that my wife came down we looked for a
house
because we were going to be moving and
uh we put a contract on the house to be
built
um and uh put down
uh sixty thousand dollars on that and uh
we're debt free except for our house so
we had some money saved and everything
else so everything was good
um fast forward a few more months and
the job did not work out uh the uh the
um uh the principal there decided that
we
weren't working well together and so now
i had
no job and moved back to ohio and
uh am currently stuck with a house uh
that i have a contract for that i can't
get out of
um and we're not selling the house that
we were going to be selling
in order to uh to uh carry this
and we're unsure what to do at this
point
because um standard mortgage
uh providers um you know uh
are expecting you to hold on to a house
for over a year
um you know they wanted to be a
principal resident so after that
all that is no longer that doesn't that
that won't affect
anything that's just that that means
you're not going to turn into a rental
is
all you promise to be owned or occupied
but you're just going to sell it
if you have to close it is the contract
not contingent upon financing
well the the contract was contingent
upon uh being able to show that you
could get financing and i did
was able to show that because we were
you know we were making all that
since then my mortgage provider said you
know under these circumstances
we're not uh interested in uh
in financing you so we're gonna have we
have to find a new way of
financing this yeah have you talked to
the builder
yeah we've tried we tried to get them to
take it back they're actually selling
the same house for forty thousand
dollars more than they paid
us on a new one that they're building
now
um well then why wouldn't they want it
to get back why wouldn't they want it
back i don't
i don't know i don't know i've actually
had a lawyer
work with them to try to get them to
fudge and they're just not budging
okay has your attorney analyzed your
contingency that was removed due to you
having financing approved that is now no
longer approved it seems to me that that
should be an out in the contract
that might be i and he has looked at it
and
um you know we basically had that
contingency
when we signed the contract he's unsure
if that can
pull us out and the question is do we
lose the 60 000
or part of it you know the other thing
you can do is this
um when i used to do flips a thousand
years ago i would often uh
sell a house that i had under contract
before
i closed on it and then have a double
closing
that lasted about five minutes so why
don't you get a good realtor and put the
house on the market now
and put it and put it on the market put
it on the market for what you paid for
it
um which is 40 000 cheaper than the
builder so you'll undercut the builder
who wouldn't
it was too stupid to take it back if i'm
the builder i want this house back
i i agree i don't understand that myself
the only problem with that solution
is that technically they still own the
mls
because we're owners in contract we are
not owning oh i don't care you can
create a whole new mls
a real estate agent can list anything
and you they just list it and say hey
this house is up for sale
and it's under it's uh you know
construction date to be completed x
and uh by the way it's forty thousand
dollars cheaper than the builders
selling the exact same model for
i think you'll get a buyer in this hot
market and get somebody to buy it
and close it uh one and a half seconds
after you do
and that funds it all right all right so
i i'll i'll i'll look into an elp
realtor then in in the other state yeah
i think that's what you need to do and
your attorney needs to get his crap
together and start looking at
contingency clause too because i think
you're out
but i could be wrong that's smart that's
a good idea yeah but a
flip like that crap put it on ten
thousand more than you paid for it make
a little money for all this trouble
still thirty thousand less than the
builder's selling it for yeah
and um you know and and and
let them pick out the final colors and
stuff let them pick it out yeah and they
can they can still customize it at this
stage
well we don't know when it's completed
they didn't have completion date but uh
yeah that
and in this hot market you probably
could do that yeah
um you might actually make some money on
this that would be weird
but um yeah wow wow well
it's um yeah that's why you have
contingencies and contracts if you can
um i buy a lot of stuff cash no
contingencies but i want a deal when i'm
doing that you didn't you weren't
getting a deal on this you paid retail
so uh you know you need you need more
wiggle room than that in a retail deal
but um yeah there you go it's
interesting
very interesting situation jonathan's in
new york city hi
jonathan what's up in your world hey
dave and chrissy thank you for taking my
call
sure sir um so
i recently accepted a new job um just to
give a little background i'm an
accountant
and the offer letter stated that
i can't perform any business activities
outside of
my employment however in the capitalist
spirit i kind of want to have a side
hustle or be able to earn some
income outside of my w-2 and i was
wondering
what my options are what's the why
behind that
what's the why behind the them
i'm not sure here's another part of
another caveat i think
um personally i think it would kind of
be
a bad book to ask about this especially
because i'm just starting new employment
i think from their perspective what
they're thinking is that
they want me to give my full energy and
attention to the job
they don't want any jobs that are going
to compete with their time as well as
compete for my energy if i'm spending my
weekends working and it's
affecting my work performance so i think
that's probably why they put that
clause in the offer letter
when do you start um i start
next monday you should have thought all
this for you accepted this offer son
i think you've done a deal and you go
over and you go to work
and you don't work side jobs because
that's what that's what you gave them
was your word on that i agree with you
it's pretty constrictive
but that's what you signed up for so you
either don't take the job
or you take the job with the terms that
you took it on and then you could ask
maybe in six months if you want to once
you've built a reputation there if you
want to ask about it
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today jonathan and jamie
are on the line in idaho falls and it
says on my screen you guys are debt free
congratulations
thank you thank you love it love it how
much have you paid off
120 000 in five years
excellent and your range of income
during that time
uh started out around 60 and then we're
up to around 100.
excellent awesome what do you all do for
a living
i'm a licensed architect and i
teach for a university online okay so
what kind of what kind of debt was this
120
000 it's our house
another paid for house i love it this is
so cool
you guys how old are you guys uh 37
i'm 35. a couple of weirdos couple of
weirdos
what's this house
it's the only place you can call
somebody call you weird and you're glad
you're like thank you for that
compliment
thank you so uh uh what's the house
worth
it's last time we checked around 300 now
yeah yeah i love it i love it pretty
lucky
what in the world happened to you guys
it caused you to do all this
well i would say um we've always been
for like raised up pretty budget
conscious and things but really it was
just
uh just someone sharing us
your plan and and we're just like hey i
think in order for us to meet our goals
and kind of the vision we wanted for our
lives we had to
had to get this out of the way yeah we
we both went to undergrad and grad
school
mostly debt-free before we kind of had
to plan we
we ended up taking out student loans for
one semester
which which we were pretty proud of and
we ended up
kind of doing the snowball effect
without really knowing we were doing the
snowball effect because it was such a
tiny
a tiny chunk and we ended up buying our
first house and we had some amazing
friends emma and michelle
who start they were talking to jonathan
about his commute they had
a similar community she's like oh you
need to tune in to the show and
he kind of loved it and and ran with it
and
kind of got me convinced too so
and so before we know it we're coloring
squares on a house
on the refrigerator yeah well having
kids who love like
coloring on anything this is a big they
love
coloring in the squares like almost more
than we did
that is cool so is that we're seeing the
picture of the house with the colors on
youtube
is that uh is that 120 squares it's
actually we started it
we started that one at 100 because we
ended up selling our first house
and we we kind of buckled down that was
right about our five-year mark where
we're like okay we're around a hundred
let's just
buckle in and so yeah 105 years
boom just like that yeah knock it out
yeah quite a good we ended up
doing the last we've been about the last
sixty thousand
in the last year because we were yeah
um we were looking at a there was a
triplex that came up
and we're like wow that looks like a
really cool investment opportunity my
husband's an architect so he's all
like we dislike property and we kept
looking at it but then we just there's
this
well dare i say it you know your voice
in the back of our head
that's like hmm should you go into debt
for this cool investment property or
should we just knock the mortgage out so
we can actually have freedom
and pay cash for an investment property
later yeah exactly yeah good yeah
so guys this is so cool what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt as
heroes
so i i would say like dream big together
and then set the goals
um and then just buckle down and grind
it out that that's the key
from my perspective because we really we
had to be working
working together and in order to
to last on the grind of it the daily
grind
um you need to have that vision that
goal out there of something you're going
towards
and working working together is key well
you make a good point because a lot of
times people call and they ask
you know some way to fast track it it
can feel like a grind especially when
you're doing the house what kept you
guys motivated for
five years of this of sticking with it
yeah i think listening to other people's
stories was huge like knowing that it
was a possibility
absolutely because i i mean
the you know the weird thing comes back
like everyone
you're just gonna be in debt for you
know the 30-year mortgage
and just like seeing hearing other
people's stories and
really going okay we could actually get
out there and
you know and also be examples to other
people who
don't think it's possible yeah that
motivation for us just
just keeping that just staying tapped
into to listening
and um and just working the plan because
that kept us going our rice and beans
dinners with the family
and just listening to the debt-free
screams and and working towards it that
just kept us going
kept us going that's cool and now you're
37 years old you don't have a payment in
the stinking world you own your house
100
you rock thank you
how does this feel oh man it's just
it's surreal it's just it feels so good
and it still hasn't entirely sunk in but
it's just yeah it feels really awesome
it's lighter
just a lot lighter yep yeah that's true
because death's heavy
yeah so heavy and when you set it down
it feels lighter that's exactly that's
so true and even just the idea of like
the word free
debt free but like there's a freedom
even in your spirit there's a freedom
and a lightness to your life when you
don't have that over your head
well done you guys that's amazing thank
you and it's it's crazy like just
keeping going i know there's probably
some pictures that pulled up our
in the last month our two-year-old broke
her leg our truck got
smacked in front of our house and
totaled and since we were able to kind
of just keep going with what we knew we
needed to do we were still able to
to deal with the crazy and meet our
goals yeah
yeah we see the uh barefoot over the uh
over the grass with one
one in a cast that's perfect yeah yeah
yeah walk through your backyard with no
shoes on it feels different when you own
it
yeah so you guys did that well done well
done well done
we got a copy of the legacy journey for
you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure
you are going to uh and have changed
your family tree changed your legacy way
to go you guys
and a copy of the total money makeover
to give away some of these people that
are watching over your shoulder watching
what you're doing or
intrigued maybe you can uh prompt one of
them into the game and change their life
so
awesome well done you guys we're very
very proud of you here at ramsey
jonathan and jamie what are the three
kids names and ages
olive is eight dash is six and velda is
two all right and a cast i like it
very good all right jonathan jamie olive
dash and velda 120 000
paid off in five years they're debt free
at 37
house and everything these are weird
people
in idaho falls making 60 to 100 count it
down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
this is how it is done this is fun
never gets old now here's what people
don't understand
because they haven't had the pleasure of
sitting in the seat for 30 years
they're 37 in the next 20 years
by the time they're 57 not only do they
have the ability
mathematically to now invest the
equivalent of a house payment which is
tens of millions of dollars over
20 to 30 years but here's what happens
his career path will be different
because now he can make choices right
and has margin
and he can work where he wants to work
when he wants to work
and he will make more money
because of that because he's not forced
to stay in a place because friday's
coming and i got bills
yeah when you're trapped you don't
become as prosperous yeah as you do when
you're free yeah
and see that's what you leave out some
of you when you're looking at this
equation and you're saying
oh i can invest in money mutual funds
and i won't pay off my mortgage and
paying off your mortgage is really
stupid now
you're really stupid when you say that
because you don't understand what
freedom does to every aspect of your
life your marriage
your health your relationships medical
bills will be lower
when you don't have this in your life
they just set down a weight
when you don't have to carry that weight
it changes
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
working on her second number one
bestseller it's on pre-sale right now
called take back your time the
guilt-free guide
to balanced living it is how to
properly address this whole subject of
balance uh use on sale now ramsey
solutions at twenty dollars
and it includes a hundred hundred and
fifty dollars worth of other items
as well so be sure and check all of that
out you don't wanna miss it out take
back
your time and uh here's the thing
uh we're also going to be doing a live
event are we going are we pushing no no
no no wait a minute well we are we are
actually
we have a quiz we do have a quiz uh and
this quiz is going to help you uncover
the root of why you feel out of balance
in the first place it's called why am i
so busy
why do i feel so busy you can text busy
b-u-s-y
to 3-3-7-8-9 free free
and find out what's the root cause of
why you feel out of balance and that's
gonna help you know what to do about it
but dave we are
actually doing an event um on september
16th and you get a ticket to that event
when you buy your copy of the book and
pre-sale so
if you wait till it launches then you
don't get that that good stuff
over the bonus item yeah e-book audio
book all that but september 16th
two days after book launch are you gonna
take it to that event if you buy it in
pre-sale so go ahead and get your copy
because we do have that event coming up
now i remember because i'm on that event
because you sure are
just hope you'll be there just reminding
me what's on my calendar
my september is something almost every
day it's all it's going to be a
wild wild month and uh that's just uh
one of the
wild elements of that month so yeah
september 16th
and if you want to take the free quiz
text busy to 33
789 uh alana is with us in helena
montana hi alana how are you
hi hi what's up oh okay
um uh my husband um his employer um
the company went public and so we've
been trying to figure out uh what to do
with the
um rsu is the stock he's been paid over
the last five and a half years and also
um he has the opportunity to purchase
stock options so we're just
thinking a lot about like how how does
what's the best way to do that obviously
um having a bunch of single stock is not
something we're comfortable with but
um also we have different uh no trading
periods
as well but um what kind of advice i
guess do you have for us
on um how long to hold it and
what what we should maybe do with that
well so you've got uh restricted stock
units uh and
what are the restrictions on it
um
sorry um i wasn't expecting that
question um
so we can't trade right now the period
will be open
here in two weeks or so and then each
quarter it seems like there'll be
a period of time um after numbers or
uh for the company or known or whatever
okay so it's not like a one year waiting
period or if it was you've already
passed that
yeah we well the the period that the
initial
public period um we will be passed here
in about a week and a half
okay and then the other periods will
just be between
quarters as we're waiting for
whatever they like to do with that i
guess well they don't want
a bunch of employees dumping stocks on a
newly public company
right before they announce earnings and
cause a dip in the stock
uh because people get scared they all
the employees are all dumping it
and so they typically do restrict your
your units
on an initial public offering for a year
that's not unusual
and up until numbers are released each
quarter so once the numbers are released
then
then you selling the stock won't affect
stock price and that's why they do that
so it's not an
unreasonable thing so what's all of this
worth that you currently own
um so we currently have um
about 35 000 dollars worth that has been
held for over a year
okay um and what is your household name
for less than a year
what's your household in uh
between 100 and 120 000 depending on
bonuses how much debt do you have not
counting your house
none good how much do you owe in your
house
nine 229 okay and you're putting fifteen
percent of your income away in
retirement and maybe step four or not
uh yes um we were definitely on baby
step four and then we did borrow into
our emergency account so we do have a
little bit to pay back into our
emergency account
but not enough that we've taken um and
stopped the 15
so you had an emergency paid back soon
yeah
yeah okay all right good and you're
getting past that good
uh all right so if you're working our
baby steps then you know
four five and six are simultaneous four
is fifteen percent of your income into
retirement
five is kids college six is pay off the
house early and so i'm using everything
i get my hands on to pay off the house
early and so as those stock
uh units become available i'm cashing
them out
and putting them on the house as fast as
i possibly can
as far as buying stock options in the
company uh that's typically
uh 15 uh off of retail right
um the numbers my husband gave me were
that it
would cost us about 27 000 to buy the
options and they would be worth
140 000 so i guess pretty close to what
you're saying
no that's a lot more than what i'm
saying that's a lot better deal than
what i'm saying fifteen percent of
a reduction in price that sounds okay
that sounds like
this sounds like you're buying it at 10
or 15 cents on the dollar
so he's got some he's got some
legitimate options there as well
here's the thing you can roll those
options without investing any cash you
can just sell them
okay okay and that that sounds like
that's going to make you
net would you say 130 over 27
make you another hundred grand 140 over
27 yeah
yeah it's gonna make you another hundred
and uh thirteen thousand on top of the
35 that you got we're about to get your
house paid off kiddo
yeah yeah it's crazy yeah sell it all
easy sell it all
okay yeah um and so do we want to try to
hold on to it for
a year is it it'll you know sell it as
soon as okay
i have no idea what the price is gonna
do
i will trade the opportunity for this
business that your husband's in i have
no idea what it is to make a lot more
money
in order to be free you got plenty of
time
to play games with stuff like options
and single stock ownership
later after you're free completely and
so
make 130 000 a year but you're sitting
on 130
140 000 worth of stock and so you've got
the equivalent of one year's income
that you're screwing around with here in
single stock now you may
do all of this stuff and look back and
that stock double in value and you go
that day ramsey lost a dead gum mine
no i want your house paid off mm-hmm
okay but you can do what you want all
right that's how we work the baby steps
right
yeah and it's interesting too because i
think that when you when you ask the
question out loud and you start to do
the math it becomes so much more clear
because having that money that is
sitting there you could be putting that
towards
the house the 35 000 and i've never
heard you talk about i guess
not as much about the company stocks but
i think that's a good question because
anybody that's in a company
that has that option needs to know what
to do with it and what to put it towards
yeah most publicly traded company stock
options
are standard employee stock purchase
they're very standardized just 15
percent off gotcha which is not enough
to mess with it yeah
um because if you look at the 52-week
high or 52-week low
they go up and down more than 15 percent
are all company stocks single stocks
yes typically okay and that's the only
thing there is it's a co it's a stock in
a single company yep
is what it is so um and these this is a
initial public offering an ipo which
means uh it's got tremendous upside
it could be it could be a real go-go but
it's got tremendous downside too right
it's the most volatile yeah of all
categories brand new companies
brand new publicly traded companies but
we only it's like fishing stories you
only hear about the ones
that you got into the boat you don't
hear about the days that you sat out
there in the sun and got nothing but a
sunburn
yes and um you caught nothing you know
and so
the guys that do an ipo and it goes
completely belly up and they make almost
nothing on her they lose half of their
money
then you don't hear those stories uh
when with your golfing buddy
you don't brag about those you're
fishing buddy right so
but uh but all of that to say i'm not
taking all the risk when you make 130
a year and you have 140 000 sitting in
your plate you go pay off your house
or move towards paying off your house
that puts us out with the ramsey show
in the books thanks to christy wright my
co-host james childs our producer
kelly daniels our associate producer and
phone screener i'm dave ramsey
we'll be back
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker
just tell alexa google assistant or siri
to play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host christy wright number
one
best-selling author ramsey personality
is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two
five five two two five her new book is
on pre-sale it will come out
september the fourteenth but if you
wanna get fifty 50 worth of extra
goodies to go with it
all for 20 bucks you can pre-order it at
ramseysolutions.com it's called take
back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance janice is with us in
oklahoma
city to start this hour off hi janice
how are you
hi dave uh i'm doing okay i'm
really pretty um very concerned about
my finances i'm 70 years old
i have no retirement my husband and i
neither one have a retirement
we are not in agreement about what we
should do with the cash that we do have
we have 25 000 cash
no cds nothing that's it
the question is we owe 27
000 on our home and the value of the
home is about 250
000. uh we have 11 000
debt on a car um
my husband wants to take the money that
we have
and pay off the car and then he says
apply the 350 dollar month car
payment towards paying off the house
my problem is i'm so stressed i at least
want to have a house to live
in and the way i see things
i don't think i can live anywhere
cheaper than where i live right now
i don't think i could even live in an
apartment for what we
would be paying a month on our home
so i need some help here
what are you living on what's your
income we have
two thousand dollars a month social
security
combined i have some income
that i get above that with a
job that i have but it's pretty
physically challenging
um i'm able to do it now but um
you know i don't know how long i'll be
able to do that
what do you make uh i probably another
two thousand a month on that
okay is your husband able to work
he has a part-time job
it's kind of whenever the the
store owner needs him and
so he has occasional income but nothing
that we
count on is he able
to work um
a little so he's got physical
limitations
yes he does okay he's got health
problems
yeah okay and that's part of you know
our situation we've had large medical
bills
and we've also made some real bad cash
investments
what do you do that makes you two
thousand dollars
i clean homes and it's physically
demanding
okay it's good money but it's physically
demanding
um
hmm
hey how many cars do you have
we have a paid off
old very dependable pickup
and then we have the one card that we
have the outstanding dead on
we also have an old uh roadster
that's probably i would say about a ten
thousand dollar
value on it
i'm sorry but the roadster is gone
okay um you have not
yeah i'm sure that's gonna break his
heart but i'm sorry
um it's gone and then that gives us ten
thousand dollars to put towards the
house
um because the roadster will sell for
enough to pay off your car
uh we can leave fifteen thousand in your
emergency fund put ten thousand towards
the house
and then that leaves you 17 to go and
you guys get in the business of the next
17 months or so getting that house paid
off
okay because with no debt at all you can
make it
it's not going to be pretty but you can
make it
right right um you know i
we don't spend money i mean everybody
spends money it
costs money to do anything but the main
thing we do is we eat out and that's not
yep a lot we don't go
here's the thing here's the thing if you
want to keep this house
you're gonna start living like you're
completely bankrupt
because you got to clean this mess up
you do not have wiggle room here
that's where all this stress is coming
from in your stomach and why you called
me
yes so you can't eat out
you're broke eating out is causing you
to clean toilets
okay yep i agree yeah and so
you know i'm sorry about in the future
you may
may be able to but right now you've got
to get a roadster sold you got to get
your car paid off and you got to get
your house paid off
and you got 25 000 and a roadster to
pull all this off
and a 2 000 income that's questionable
because we don't know how much longer
you can do this at 70 years old
right so we have got to get you clear of
this debt
before your before you start losing the
ability to work like he has
otherwise you're going to end up selling
this house and buying a condo for a
hundred thousand and have a hundred
thousand dollar slush fund to live on
and have a life now you can go and do
that now if you want
okay i'm listening to you well you got a
250 000 house right
yes so if you sell it today you're
debt-free take a hundred thousand by a
hundred thousand dollar condo
two-bedroom
move yourself into it and that's your
retirement home
and that's how you're gonna retire and
that that enables you to
not be stressed and not be worried and
you've got a hundred thousand dollars
to invest over there it'll make you a
little bit of money and
you know that's a much better
mathematical equation but i'm guessing
that that's going to cause an awful lot
of emotional pain
well and also you know the hoa fees
would be
no problem no no no
you you can live in a hundred thousand
dollar condo in oklahoma city
it's just gonna come down to making the
choice janice like you're gonna have to
make a choice you're either going to
get out of this debt or you're going to
have to leave that hat like
something has to give this is not
working right now which is why you feel
that tightness in your chest but you can
fix it you've got
several ways to fix it but you have to
make a choice and commit to doing that
you can't
he's going to have to work all his
health will allow him you're going to
work all your health will allow you
you're not going to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
you're going to sell the roadster and
you guys are going to get serious about
paying this thing off
otherwise you need to sell it and move
to 100 000 condo
you'll be better off or something like
that
this is the ramsey show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices and
they make it simple to shop
blinds shades and interior shutters with
easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed
perfect fit go to blinds.com and take
advantage of this week's special
savings
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
she's the number one best-selling author
and getting ready to be so again the new
book is take back your time the
guilt-free guide
to life balance it's on sale at ramsey
solutions for 20
including an extra 50 worth of goodies
which also
includes a ticket to the live stream
event she and i will be doing on balance
and that's on september the 16th the
book
actually launches on september 14th
which is when we will ship it to you
why would you buy it now when it comes
out september 14th because we're going
to give you 50
worth of stuff as a bribe to get you to
go ahead and do it now
that's that's simple it's called
marketing i think
believe it or not y'all it's august here
at ramsey we think of august as a second
new year we've noticed that once
everyone is done with the distractions
of summer they're ready to kick things
into high gear
and you have goals that you want to
reach like getting ready for christmas
which is here in about 30 seconds right
um
and uh you know you got things you need
to do doyle to help you get back on
track we're running a great
new deal every week starting at only ten
dollars this week our back to school
sale
get up to 71 off books kids products and
curriculum
and today only our team is marking down
our family favorite
the adventure pack only 40 5.99 that's
the lowest price of the year for
teaching your kids
the whole adventures of junior from
financial peace junior
all of this at ramseysolutions.com we're
also having a lot of fun celebrating the
pre-order launch of ken coleman's new
book from paycheck to purpose
with a 500 cash giveaway
every week this month and we're giving
away a grand prize of three
thousand dollars and i've already
mentioned christie's book take back your
time
the guilt-free guide to life balance all
of this happening at ramsey solutions
including the
cash giveaway no purchase necessary for
that check it all out
daily you have chances to win text cash
to 33
789 cash to 33 789
shelly is with us in spokane hi shelly
how are you
uh i'm gonna get you bless more than i
deserve to be
there you go good plan what's up how can
we help
okay i love two things in life
planning events like weddings and saving
money
and i'd like to combine the two and find
a little niche where i can
help couples to plan that party without
spending the down payment on a house
over it all right
i just don't know how to do it
i do little things like when there is a
clearance on kind of fancy wear
at st michaels for tables i buy them
on clearance i i
buy stuff on craigslist as far as
tablecloths and stuff like that
i may have a venue that can be my go-to
venue depending upon the wedding that
i'm helping plan for my
cousin's daughter and i'm trying to do
it sensibly but
i am not a business person
and i don't know exactly how to go about
it i know how to go about
finding people that i need that can help
me as far as
certain aspects but it's all really
overwhelming
i don't know how to set up a website and
it's just
i really want to do this but um i don't
want to fail
hey shelly i want you to know that
exactly what you said is what i've heard
for 10 years
and you're not alone every single person
getting started feels the exact
same way i hear those exact same words
i'm not a business person
i don't know what i'm doing i don't want
to fail so i just first want to
encourage you
you're not alone and that's normal
you're doing something new the great
news is it doesn't mean you can't do
this you can do this and you will do
this you're going to do this like
everybody else does it
which is just being scrappy and taking
it one step at a time
so i want to give you some really
tactical things you can do
because when you uh you you accomplish
one tactical step it's going to build
your confidence
it's also going to help you make
progress in this direction okay if i
give you a list of things to do will you
do it
yes ma'am okay they're they're easy i
promise okay i'm not a scary teacher i
mean i might seem scary i don't mean to
here's what i want you to do first i
want you to do a little research
on the wedding planning business you can
just stalk people in your area you can
stalk people online i don't care how you
do it
i want you to get a list of what are the
typical
services a wedding planner covers you
just need to know what those are you
probably know the basics from
cakes to linens to florals that type of
thing
but i want you to get a comprehensive
list
i want you to make a whole list okay and
okay and then that's going to help you
know
what areas that you need to source that
you don't already have
a source for uh and that's just going to
give you a good starting point
okay then i want second i want you to
think about your pricing
there are several different ways to
charge in the wedding planning business
you can do it as a percentage of budget
you can do it as a flat fee obviously it
will include
what a package people buy if they just
want you to help them day of
that's going to be less expensive than
if someone wants you to plan their whole
wedding for six months with them or a
year
so think about your pricing and and
you've got some options here this is
your business i know that sounds scary
but it's
it's not scary it's exciting this is
your business you can price it and
structure the the pricing how you want
to but i want you to do a little
research on
on what's out there and what's normal
and and think about what you want to do
okay so first we're going to make a list
of all the services that are typically
covered so you know what you're going to
cover
and where you need to do a little bit
more homework find some sourcing
i want you to think about your pricing
okay and then i want you to think about
even some of the language
around how you talk about your business
because i love
how you talked about it to me i think
that could be your elevator pitch right
there
i love planning weddings and i love
saving money and i want to help you do
both
that could be it it's clear and it it
articulates your niche
you are the wedding planner on a budget
and that's beautiful that's awesome it's
so clear why people should come to you
because you're going to specifically
help them plan a wedding on a budget i
love it
um so those are just some tactical
practical things the other thing i want
you to do is when you are planning this
wedding who is it your cousin
your sisters my cousin's daughter
okay she was rustic without country and
i've
nailed a lot of it we've got the venue
and we've got the catering
all set up i have all the tablescapes
taken care of
everything that needs to be done other
than a dj and a photographer
and the event the people that have the
events at the place
have contacts with both okay okay okay
here's what i want you to do
i i think that's great here's what i
want you to do
this is a trial run for planning a
wedding for you so what i want you to do
is take notes
what are the things you didn't expect
that you encountered what are the things
you learned
what are the things you want to do
differently next time what are the
things that you loved that works well
that you want to do again
you take notes on this whole experience
from your perspective
and then certainly ask for feedback from
this family member
afterwards once she's home from a
honeymoon and all that say hey what
could i've done better or different
if you do these simple tactical things
that i've just given you to do
you are on your way to doing it and
it's gonna build your confidence but i
want you to stay on the phone shelly
because we are having our business
boutique conference in october
14th through the 16th i'll be speaking
along with dave a lineup of incredible
speakers
we're going to give you a ticket to that
event if you can't come in person we'll
give you a live stream ticket
but stay on the line we'll make sure
kelly gets you a ticket so you can come
get all that you will need from
marketing sales money
all the things we're gonna teach you how
to start and grow this thing so we're
just
you're gonna do it and you're gonna
you're gonna learn what you need to be
able to do it
it's a three-day conference and it is
packed yeah you will leave it
emotionally and intellectually exhausted
in the best way in the best possible way
because you you you listen if you want
to come down and goof off don't come
because this is like we're going we're
going to turn on fire
that's right we have a lot of fun and we
teach you a lot we got a drink we turn
on a fire hose
so it's uh we're you're gonna you're
gonna leave knowing
and you're never again gonna be able to
say oh i don't know anything about
business that's right
every single woman that walks in that
room or that tunes it online thinks
exactly what shelly thought i don't know
what i'm doing
i'm not a business person i don't want
to fail and they walk out of there ready
to charge hell with a water pistol like
they know how to do this they this
one woman said she goes i came feeling
like a mom
with an idea and i left a business owner
there's an identity shift
that happens in those three days and
you're going to be there shelly i'm
excited for you
that's a business boutique it is coming
up in october october 14th through the
16th here in nashville or
on live stream you can get your tickets
and all at ramseysolutions.com for the
rest of you
this is the ramsey show
chrissy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five in
buffalo new york matthew and tara
are on the line to tell us their debt
free story
hey guys how are you oh we're doing
great
excited to be here how much of you guys
paid off
uh well we started to 10 years ago with
about 65 000
but three years ago we still had forty
three thousand to go
okay and what's been your range of
income
um ranged anywhere from thirty to thirty
six thousand a year
okay and what kind of debt was the sixty
five thousand
uh it was a mix of uh thirty eight
thousand in school loans
sixteen thousand family loans for our
house and eleven thousand in credit card
debt
wow kind of normal very normal
so what happened 10 years ago what
happened three years ago they got you
guys going
so ten years ago is when we got married
and we started out
just making minimum payments planning to
pay off the school loans
and eventually build a house
and three years ago looking at it we'd
been
at it for seven years and still had 43
000 to go
i was getting pretty tiring and so we
decided
to get serious tara got involved
much more strongly
helped us to start a emergency fund and
i have a small business so my my income
tends to fluctuate
a little bit and so she put together an
emergency fund
and we started doing a cash base and
then a year ago
we started following your plan wow how
did you find us
um i don't know i think probably just
somewhere on youtube i saw
videos about being debt free i love all
the personalities
um and so i i kind of just grew up on
you know watching videos and
making you know making life better for
myself and so
um i really loved all your stuff and
we're believers and so to me it's just
like wow this is amazing like
you know and it was just kind of easy to
i mean the plan makes so much sense so
it's just like
let's just do this okay
so when you got more involved you went
to matthew and said okay
now we're going to do it my way we tried
it your way for seven years now we're
gonna do it my way
yeah yeah i mean our our upbringings
financially were a little different i
actually grew up with
handling cash a lot more so i was super
comfortable going all cash like if it's
not there we're not buying it
because there's no money but i yeah i
just
i something clicked in me a couple you
know a couple years ago
and i was like man like we just gotta
get out like this has been so long it's
been such
such a long haul we worked so hard it
was like we just
like our money should be going where we
want it to um
you know and two like i i want the kids
to not see us
ball in chain not living out our our
dreams or the calling that god has for
us and so
um yeah so you know we we both got on
board
not that it really took a lot of
convincing but uh
the proof was kind of in the pudding
once once uh some of the smaller loans
started to get paid off
um and the momentum was just phenomenal
it was like let's
do this like we kicked into such a high
gear it was like so
it was so awesome i love how you guys
described that because i think matthew
the way that you said it you said um you
know we got
serious and there's such a difference
between
plugging along making minimum payments
not really going anywhere no one's
excited about that no one's making any
kind of progress with that but when you
get serious and you get
committed it does create that momentum
you're talking about tara
and that's what makes the difference
that's what actually gets you out dave i
always quote you when you say you can
wander into debt
you cannot wander out you're going to
have to get fired up and you guys did
and you see the difference in the
numbers once you got fired up so well
done
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
um i i say a budget you cannot do it
without a budget i mean we
we i meal plans like to the scent when i
went to the grocery store because i was
like this is what it is like
you know and we can't go over that and i
think budgeting it like our you know
electric our utilities are pretty
expected and reliable but like food it's
so easy to spend so much money and so to
me
it was like you cannot do it without a
budget and you can't do it
i personally i enjoy doing it um with
just using cash
only personally yeah i would say
before you can get out of debt you have
to stop going into debt
and uh for us a huge key to that was
having that emergency fund buffer
yeah that's why we do that that's i
didn't start out with that as baby step
one back and when i very first started
but i learned quickly that
uh you've got to have a little bit of a
room a little bit of wiggle room there
and baby step one to get moving
so way to go you guys we're so proud of
you
way to go heroes you took control of
your life
ding ding ding i love it well we've got
a copy of the legacy
journey for you that is the next chapter
in your story for sure
uh you've changed your family tree and
changed the whole direction of
everything in the last three years
is a whole new whole new chapter for you
and we've also got a copy of the total
money makeover for you so you can give
that to someone and pay it forward
and uh get them started maybe on this
idea of
uh you know complete focus completely
laying your ears back and going into it
i love it all right so you got the three
kiddos with you to do the debt-free
scream
yes we do their names and ages
gracie is eight uh kenny is six
and vincent is two perfect
sounds awesome good looking guys we see
them here on the
picture on youtube popping up so well
done well done guys
ah i love it yeah all right matthew tara
gracie kenny and vincent
uh are 43 65 000 paid off over 10 years
but 43 in the last three years make it
30
to 36 count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
three two one
yeah that is
how it's done that's awesome i love it
so
beautiful so fabulous so well played
yeah and and you know what's interesting
is that they paid off almost all their
debt in three years
yeah there's another part of that story
but you know
it's things change when you get sick and
tired
of being sick and tired when you finally
say i've
had it that's when you open up a small
business
that's when you get out of debt that's
when
you know the kids are made to behave for
the first time ever
you know when you finally say that's it
i've had it we're not living like this
anymore yeah
and you know you have to reach that
point and
it's it is a healthy level of
frustration or anger yeah because it
motivates you to do something different
it's hard to do something different not
just the discipline of
of paying off your debt not going into
debt just change
is hard the habit changing is hard uh
the mental energy to think about we've
got to sit down every month and do a
budget
is hard new things are hard but if
you're going to face that hard and have
that discipline
you've got to have that visceral anger
frustration whatever to motivate you
because otherwise you're not going to
face the hard but you've got to face it
and make those changes if you're ever
going to get to
to making your debt-free screaming and
experiencing that life you have to
actually go through that
but so many people don't they get stuck
at the oh that's hard i think i'm just
going to
keep on keeping on you know making
minimum payments the sad thing is is
that normal in america sucks
yeah yeah and so widely accepted we're
all just okay with [ __ ] but it's also
by the way
extremely comfortable oh sure yeah your
your comfort zone
in america is really big yeah you have a
really big
comfort zone yeah i mean you can wander
around and do stupid and have a pretty
decent life
oh yeah and people will applaud you yeah
and they're like oh look at you you've
got to go
look at your new car yeah look at your
new vacation
and you keep buying stuff that you don't
need with money you don't have to
impress people you don't even really
like
and you keep on this path and you keep
on this path and you just hang out in
the comfort zone
and then something happens finally
that jolts you awake and say the pain
of staying the same is now
exceeding the pain of change and that's
the only time you'll change that's right
you finally wake up and say i am sick
and tired of being sick and tired
i'm sick of this dull existence of
mediocrity
and i'm about to bust up into something
and create some excellence in my life
sick of not having any money yeah sick
of whatever
yeah you know let's get her done name it
feel it and then do something about it
get it baby
get it this is the ramsay show
our scripture of the day first
corinthians 9 24 do you not
know that in a race all the runners run
but only one gets the prize
run in such a way as to get the prize
florence nightingale said i attribute my
success to this
i never gave or took any
excuse i bet
she didn't can you even imagine
oh my goodness i love it that's fabulous
christy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author with a new book
on sale take back your time the
guilt-free guide
to life balance is my co-host today
the phone number here is triple triple
eight eight two five five
two two five robert's in oakland
california hey robert how are you
good uh hi dave and christy hi
my wife my wife and i are in a good
place we uh
however we do live in a very high cost
part of california
yeah we just retired a few months ago
and we want to pay off our home
which is our only debt however our plan
was to reach a nest egg amount
to be able to pay off our home and then
have our nest egg at a level where we
can live comfortably the rest of our
life
uh we're we're short of that goal and i
i think i know what you would probably
say but because
but because we live in such a high cost
area i'm wondering what you think of my
plan
now that plan is okay to grow our
investments another 280 000
before we pay off our home okay so
what's your nest egg today
it's almost 1.5 million and what's the
take to pay off the house
uh 280 000 and we would our goal was to
have 1.5 million
after we paid off our home yeah okay
so here's the thing how's the money
invested what's it invested in
it's uh invested well it's in 403 b's
and roth iras mostly and inside of that
in mutual funds
yeah mutual fund so are you getting a
right of return uh
10 or north of that average yes
absolutely
wait yes yes i'm doing well all right so
let's just say 10 percent because that's
conservative probably
um yeah every how old are you 66
okay every seven years it's going to
double if you don't touch it right
so 1.5 is going to be three in
seven years okay
or uh one point minus whatever we take
out yeah or
one point two or one point two will be
two point eight
or two point two point four i'm sorry in
seven years
so um i mean i said three yeah two point
that's that's right
i'm sorry so um i mean
you gotta run your budget out can you
not live on the income that a million
two creates
yeah we can but it we might have to cut
back on our lifestyle
but you don't have a house payment
anymore
correct and you still can't make it on
the income you can't live 120
000 with no house payment
oh yeah we can yeah we can absolutely we
can
um we're anticipating we're anticipating
a withdrawal rate of around five percent
not ten percent
okay that we pay ourselves about five
percent of our investments
okay so
here's uh i mean you can do whatever you
want to do you call me and ask me
yeah if i woke up in your shoes i'd
write a check and pay off my house today
and i would change i changed my
withdrawal rate to seven percent until i
got my nest egg where i want and then i
drop it back down to five
okay and you're going to come out about
the same place
but you will have had no house debt all
through this time
okay and the house is worth currently
you said how much
uh 600 almost 670
000. okay so your net worth two million
bucks give or take good
way to go man you did it congratulations
how much of this did you inherit only
around 40 000 for my wife and my wife
and my
parents so how did you become a
millionaire what you do
a 2 million we we live within our means
all of our adult life we live debt free
and we saved very well
and invested very well we were in
ministry so we never made a lot of money
we just
lived frugally and we invested well what
was your average income through your
life
well it's probably
70 to 80 000 maybe so you never made 100
grand
well we did the last few years because
my wife and i were both on staff that
only for a few years we made over a
hundred thousand
and you got two million dollars well
i'm so proud of you pastor you did it
man
you lived out the principles of that
book you've been teaching from
well done yeah well done live on lesson
you make stay out of debt
have a plan i mean this is this is
this is what you did and this is by the
way what the typical millionaire does
the everyday millionaire in america
today
they're all over the place and they're
not evil they didn't steal it from
anybody
and no none of that money is yours it's
his now
he's a generous guy he'll give you some
if you're hungry but
i mean you did it man i'm so proud of
you well done
very well done yeah if i woke up in your
shoes i'll be debt free let me tell you
something that you don't anticipate
you you you taught you taught from the
pulpit for many years right
yeah and uh have you had this experience
before i have from the pulpit
uh where i teach a biblical truth
and then when i actually have the
opportunity to
walk in that truth i have a different
feel about it a different insight a
different paradigm of it do you know
what i'm talking about
i do yeah when you pay off this house
you're going to understand proverbs 22 7
at a different level the borrower is
slave to the lender
there's going to be something in you
that's going to flip like a switch
when you pay this house off and you're
not anticipating that
yeah well i'm we're looking forward to
that and i i agree with you i deal with
that
yeah by the end of the day brother by
the end of the day
you're gonna feel it tonight you're
gonna be seeing it you're gonna be
singing hymns about freedom
it's happening tonight robert hope
you're ready you know
the the times that you have something
happen like
um uh those that are last will be first
that you know that that i came to serve
uh i came to live give life in abundance
jesus said
and when you hear that the first time or
two as a
christian or somebody that's a potential
christian even you
you you kind of hear it but when you
walk in it
and it gets all over you it's a
different thing yes yeah it takes an
experience
it's going from your head to your heart
from just the idea that you understand
intellectually to
feeling it in in your spirit there's a
reality yeah
it's it becomes reality it's no longer
theory yeah
and um that's true of a lot of things in
in life
and in scripture but um uh
and especially someone who's devoted
their life to serving god
um when you do something that's you know
he's very mathematical he's really got a
plan he's a planner
and when you do something that that you
know it's almost stepping out on faith a
little bit
it's not because you've got plenty of
margin but it's not like he's taking a
risk here
i mean because hey pastor if you hate
being out of debt you can always go get
you a mortgage yeah i mean
so uh it's not like you're stuck or
something but the uh uh
but but what happens is you don't it it
kind of catches you off guard because
i mean i remember with that that feeling
where i went
wow it feels like cold mountain air just
blew in the room and
fresh air you know wow
there was a moment you know and you just
there's something that happens and i
uh it is a spiritual experience because
there's a spiritual principle involved
here yeah
and uh you know and the you know the
same thing's true that in the house of
the wise or stores of choice food and
oil
my wife feels different when we have an
emergency fund
i feel different yeah when we have
stores
of wealth and it's not because we're
greedy and it's not because we're
hoarding it's not because we're not
generous or not being willing to help
someone right
but but there that that margin that
money gives you is a spiritual principle
the security and the
the yeah absolutely it's a stewardship
issue
just being wise very cool stuff good
show today christy this is fun
christy wright new book is take back
your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance james charles is our
producer kelly daniels our associate
producer
i'm dave ramsey your host we'll be back
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you